AI算出蛋白質會折成什麼形狀。
做出AlphaFold的人拿了諾貝爾化學獎。
這段故事很多人講過。
這次講的人當年坐在評審席上,他叫Charles Oaksilk首爾大學化學系教授,做蛋白質結構預測做了27年。
這集是韓國公共電視EBS的科學節目,為了今年的諾貝爾獎祭做的9月18號播出。
蛋白質是氨基酸串成的長鏈
會自己折成立體的形狀
形狀決定它能做什麼
以前用實驗解一個形狀
博士生得花上四五年
所以有人想直接用算的
難在一個蛋白質平均有300個氨基酸
每一個都有好幾種白法
那不是困難的,那是不可能的
不可能的
三百勝的那句話是很緊張的
那是怎麼計算的
一種是不可能,只能靠預測
1994年,做結構預測的人辦了一場全球比賽
叫Case App,每兩年一次
拿實驗鋼解出來,還沒公開的結構出題
再用實驗的答案打分數
他的團隊常在這裡拿獎牌
Case App 比賽的時候
教授是參賽者
你也參加過,但是在Alphafold的時期,你也參加過審査委員組
你也參加過審査委員組
我也是參加者,所以我也參加過不參加的審査委員組
我也是參加過不參加的審査委員組
這真的很厲害
這是真正的PRO TEAM QUEEN
2018年,Alphafold的第一版本出現了
2020年,Alphafold 2獲得了獎勵
當時審査委員組在斯維斯聯合會議中
在評測會議中
他竟然這麼好
之前的分數是這樣的
突然那一回合的分數
上升了很多
阿爾法福德突然
那時候你有什麼感覺
就是
人類
哇
要說他輸了
還是
他做得太好了
在我生活中
我非常高興看到這件事實現了不可思議的想法
科學家不只是為了勝利
我們也是為了幾百年來的科學家的戰爭
獲得了更多的獎項
但如果我們之間有一個人
在這次戰爭的科學文明之上
達成了任何的目標
作為同時代的人
看到這件事也是一個很大的喜悅
你只是以喜悅來接受
如果是我
我會非常生氣
似乎被奪回了
但教授說
在AlphaFold出道後
成績突然變得非常好
人們都沒有問過你
你到底是怎麼做的
所以比賽開始了
那一年夏天的問題都解決了
在12月發表了
那時候AlphaFold的團隊發表了
也發表了John Jumper
也發表了Demis Hassabis的代表
也在網上發表了
因為是新冠病毒的季節
所以人們很想知道我如何得到這麼好的分數
所以想問一下
但我只是隨便發表
並沒有告訴人們我非常想知道的
但我可以透過網絡
那兩位呢?
我可以透過網絡提出很多問題
因為很驚訝
對,我可以透過AI解釋
人們也知道我透過AI解釋
但我又如何解釋
我又如何解釋
當然你會透過AI解釋
最低限度提供教育
只要提供提供時間
我們會更多人選擇
後來說要提供文章
但文章的詳細是很清楚的
真的嗎?那我應該要承認了
文章真的要很久了
真的嗎?
對,要很久了
技術階層
他們想要自己的技術階層
可以保持自己的時間
我可以這樣想
你一定有看過文章的實例
內容如何?
有什麼秘訣?
他說光有資料還不夠
AlphaFold另外吃進了兩樣東西
一樣是物理
原子之間怎麼互相拉扯
這些規則被寫進了模型
另一樣是演化
同一種蛋白質
人跟鯨魚馬身上都有
形狀差不多
半基酸的順序卻各不相同
把這些清晰的序列擺在一起比
就找得到結構的線索
你把那些解決完畢的問題
數十年來的科學家都在流血解決了這些問題
AI就出現了
解決了這些問題
這時候科學家的反應
應該會非常強烈
你覺得如何?
是的
我非常驚訝
現在有些人
想知道自己在做什麼
發佈了轉轉波和迪米斯哈薩比斯
當時人們的所有問題
都在解決了鏈接的解決問題
主持人接著問
全球的蛋白質
2億的蛋白質
你認為幾個蛋白質
是AlphaFold完美預測的嗎?
AlphaFold只要有
阿米洛丹的級別
就可以預測它的形狀
所以它在認識的
幾乎所有蛋白質的
形狀計算
然後在數碼搜索
2億的蛋白質
是很接近的?
是的,但是預測是預測的
所以有些是對的,有些是錯的
我沒看過
大概半個月左右
半個月左右
這樣算起來很厲害
而且他也有說
我這個我都很自信
我這個我都不自信
他也有這樣說
他自己不自信就用三分之一
學得好學生的話
我這個不自信
這個我都不自信
他就這樣說
就像這樣
那時候你會繼續研究嗎
我相信會
我相信大家會用這方法
我們都會努力使用
我相信大家會使用
對,我們會使用
但是如果AlphaFold說
這個構造我覺得適合我
現在可以說是正確的
所以這些東西
不需要實驗
我現在可以相信
所以如果我們可以
用AlphaFold去預測
這個構造的話
我們就不需要實驗了
而且更有趣的是
摩擦的蛋白質
為什麼摩擦成這樣的效果
更有趣的研究
所以現在
有很多科學家在使用
一名大學生
在五年內
流血泡淚
現在不需要再做了
現在AI出現了
那你認為
研究會如何改變
在談蛋白質設計方面
當我們談論現有的東西,更好的方式是最好的方式。
以前,很多人說過是工程。
現在,我們可以完全地創造新的東西。
我們可以創造新的東西。
我們稱之為Denovo設計。
其實我認為這是神的領域
我沒想過在《阿爾法福爾》出現之前
我能做到這樣的東西
從零設計
就是先想好要他做什麼
再回頭設計一個自然界沒有的蛋白質去做
他說最有用的地方是心藥
很多難治的病
關鍵在某一個蛋白質出了問題
設計一個專門去卡住它的分子
就有機會治
他的實驗室也自己開發設計用的AI
지금까지設計的蛋白質也非常多
我們在設計20-30個目標
我們在設計很多沒有在過去的新的蛋白質
如果研究成功
就像奧運獎一樣
對嗎?
可能
如果我們能做到沒有在過去的東西
我們有可能
對吧?
你不斷在那邊說什麼
當然要去
我們有準備了幾個人
只要成功
奧運獎就確定了
他說的那位諾貝爾得主
節目畫面上打出來的新聞寫的是
John Jumper
也就是2020年在線上報告
AlphaFold的那個人
四年後他跟海斯貝斯一起拿了諾貝爾化學獎
就是多少分量
那麼將來
當蛋白質設計
會有什麼效果
讓我們接近病毒治療的
教授
現在已經接近了
德米斯、哈薩比斯
和其他AI領導
大概10年、15年
就會處理所有病毒
真的嗎
15年就要健康了
健康了
要稍微支持一下
那真的可以享受MC的永生
真的
我真的想這樣做
作為一位科學家
一直在研究蛋白質
我最終的目標是什麼
如果我一直在走某種方向
那就是理解生命
理解生命存在的世界
以這種理解
創造出我們需要的東西
這就是我所追求的方向
AlphaFold解掉了他花大半輩子在做的題目
他的第一個反應是高興
現在他用AI做世界上沒有的蛋白質
同一條路上多了Google和Anthropic
這個第一名他做的不太安穩
原影片39分鐘
前半段他從頭講蛋白質
也講到疫情那年
他的團隊把別人解出來的新冠級蛋白片段拼起來
補上缺的根部
做出完整的立體結構
同桌做天文的來賓也說
一張星空照片裡有幾千萬個天體
不靠AI根本分不完
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多